so um this is the first time I'm kind of
doing a keynote um and when I started
this talk I honestly didn't really know
what I wanted to talk about uh like
there was like a serious amount of Doubt
on my end so I figured you know that how
do you do a keynote well maybe start
with a blank canvas that felt like kind
of the right thing to do and then
eventually they led me to come up with a
t like talk title and that's when the
ball really got
rolling so this is what I'm going to be
talking about today and I'm honestly
very excited about it too because um
basically what we'll be doing is we're
going to talk about ideas that are worth
thinking about and I think it might be
fun to start with what I think has been
the most thought-provoking article of
the last year at least to me so what I'm
going to do now I'm going to start by
talking about a data set and um you know
this is a data set with stuff that comes
out of a smartwatch so you got to
imagine we've got about like 1,800
people uh we've got their body mass
index uh we know whether or not they
were male or female that's also in this
data set and we also know the steps per
day so this is definitely one of those
smart watchy data sets people track
themselves that sort of
thing but this is not the most
interesting part about the data set just
yet you see this data set was used in a
statistics course so a university uh
with like Master students uh master's
degree in statistics if I recall
correctly uh so these are people who are
used to like looking at data and they
kind of figured well we're interested in
understanding how people analyze data so
we're going to give this one group a
couple of hypotheses to check so you're
given a data set and you're given some
hypotheses so things like uh oh check
the correlation of the number of steps
and the body mass index for men compare
that to women uh check the difference in
number of steps men and women like these
are hypothesis to check and by doing
that you'll hopefully understand the
story of the data
set and then the other group they just
said well just look at the data like
just have a look uh what conclusions are
there in this data
set and here's what the data set
actually looks like so on the x axis you
can see the number of steps on the y
axis you can see the body mass index and
whether or not it's a blue or a red dot
um means if you're male or female this
is obviously a synthetic data set but
the question is which of these two
groups actually found
out so we had the first group who got a
couple of hypothesis to check and the
other group didn't get hypothesis to
check they are both from the same class
right they're kind of like randomly
split but it turns out that the group
who didn't get a hypothesis was way more
likely to understand that the data set
was just nonsense and there was a
gorilla in the data
set and to me that felt extremely
thought-provoking because if a
hypothesis is like can be a liability in
the field of
Statistics what can be a liability in
our
field cuz you would like I had a couple
of classes in statistics you're supposed
to do hypotheses but apparently
something about that makes it hard to
find this gorilla so that to me is
extremely thought-provoking but it also
reminded me of something that happened
somewhat early in my
career so I was at this website I mean
company behind the website obviously um
and this website was trying to recommend
secondhand cars to people it was like a
use case that they had um and you know
if you want to recommend things you
think recommender recommender alos let's
go so you read the book and you quickly
learn about these algorithms like Matrix
factorization was a little bit before
neural networks I guess but the way you
typically do that is you do this big
compute thing machines go room and then
for each person you know what thing you
might be able to recommend you store
that in the database because it's a very
expensive thing to calculate and then
what you can do is you can use that as a
cache to go ahead and recommend stuff
like person comes to the website we
might be able to recommend something
stuff like
that however this wouldn't never really
work because the thing with a secondhand
car is the moment that one person buys
it it's gone and you cannot recommend it
anymore um if you think about Netflix I
can definitely recommend the same show
to someone else but the used car once
it's gone it's really gone and I cannot
recommend it anymore and I might have to
update the cache and oops that is
actually going to break like the update
is not going to be as fast as it needs
to
be so you can imagine that with this way
of thinking the team kind of got stuck
like we know how to do recommenders
we've got books about that but this was
just never really going to
work so this is kind of like the
opposite of a cold start this is kind of
like a hot end basically which I also
thought was just kind of
interesting so then we started
rethinking like okay that's obviously
not going to work like what what else
might
well we started just looking at some
cars just sell themselves it's like a
phenomenon that we just noticed like
there's a couple of cars that even if
you don't promote them or anything
anything you just kind of know that it's
a popular car and it will just get sold
at some point anyway but we also noticed
there were just some cars that were kind
of on the edge like they didn't always
automatically sell themselves even
though there probably is a market for it
it's just that people might not have
found it so now we figured well instead
of doing the recommend their thing how
about we do a classifier thing where
we're going to make a like a little
little robot that predicts whether or
not it'll it'll sell itself and if the
car that comes in won't necessarily sell
itself we'll just boost it in the search
for results so we had this elastic
search set up that was actually pretty
good at like inserting and removing it
was pretty robust against that and it
had this feature where you were able to
boost so you were able to say well this
item uh put that higher up in the queue
and you can imagine if it's a car that
won't sell itself automatically but it
gets a little bit more eyeballs it
actually has a larger chance of getting
sold which means that in total more cars
actually do end up getting
sold so the person might find it and
conversely and this is I think the most
interesting thing we are no longer
recommending a car to a person we are
recommending a person to a car which is
like the other way around of thinking
about it and that way a thinking was
actually the reason that this system
worked pretty dang
well but then you do kind of Wonder you
know what makes it harder for us to
consider the thing on the left as
opposed to the thing on the right
because the moment you think oh I got to
recommend stuff you immediately start
thinking like oh the item has to go to
the user and it's a little bit less
natural it seems to think about the user
has to go to the
item and then when you start thinking
about why this might be well um just
around the time that these recommenders
started getting like really popular we
had this thing called the Netflix prize
this was like I think like the million--
dollar prize people could win there was
some Netflix data there like in the time
that they still had DVDs and this was
like the one example in all the
recommender textbooks um there was
someone who won this leaderboard prize
so that's the algorithm we just started
teaching
everyone so when you think recommend
there you typically think of the thing
that was taught which is this Netflix
prize thing and you kind of maybe forget
there's other ways to solve the problem
as well simply because that thing got so
popular and it's not just the Netflix
prize that we're dealing with here if
you think about the larger picture we've
also got this thing called kaggle
there's the data science competitions is
a very popular website and that also
drives a lot of popularity for
approaches and
ideas but you do want to rethink once in
a while and I sometimes wonder it might
not be a hypothesis in my mind but there
there are these things that are making
it hard for me to sometimes be
creative and some of that has to do with
bad advice that people have given me in
the past so when I was sort of a younger
data scientist person like 10 years ago
or so people would tell me Vincent don't
reinvent the wheel like we already have
some approaches just go ahead and reuse
those but if you think about the wheel
for just a second I mean the real the
wheel totally got reinvented like a
bunch of times and that was a good
thing like um if I don't want to have a
wooden horse car wheel on the airplane I
think that would be a legitimately bad
idea but then I mean for us right um
wheels are nice physical objects we have
physics uh there's reasons why there are
constraints but if you're dealing with
software there shouldn't really be a
reason why you would constrain yourself
to one way of thinking about the problem
but it is something that at least it
seems to be happening so then what might
happen if we just allow ourselves to
rethink the wheel once in a while I
think that's a very interesting and
thought provoking thing to just do more
of and with that in mind I um I'm going
to work towards a demo now I'm going to
do that by talking about another data
set so uh this data set is not about the
BMI thing this data set is all about
credit cards and in particular it's
about fraud um you might have seen this
data set before it's a pretty popular
data set online effectively it's
basically a big table with lots of
features of a transaction and some of
these transactions are fraud so we have
like a one or a zero indicating was it
fraudulent or
not so okay how do you tackle this well
typically what you would do is you would
just attach a model maybe a neural
network of sorts um and you would do
something clever because this data set
of course has a class imbalance like for
every 10,000 non-f fraudulent examples
you've got like 18 maybe fraudulent
examples so there's a risk that this
model is totally going to overfit you
want to be careful with that because it
might affect performance so you want to
be careful and then you read the book
and the typical advice is well you do
the class weight thing you're going to
tell the algorithm well uh the fraud
cases if you get those right that's
worth way more gradient points uh than
the non-f fraud cases and this is like a
general technique that people like to
use to sort of combat this uh class and
balance thing
here but it does feel like we're reusing
the same thinking uh if I'm honest like
we're we're still in algorithm land when
we are thinking about this problem this
way and you can kind of wonder is this
kind of a wheel that deserves to be
reinvented is this performance number
really the thing is that all we need or
is there maybe something
missing so I started playing around with
this and I would like to give you a
small
demo
uh we have the screen this works cool um
so in the background uh or in the
foreground I think let's make this just
a little a little bit bigger there we go
this is a Jupiter notebook um I'm sure
you're all familiar with this uh and
what I'm doing here is I'm loading in
the credit card data set I'm using
polers it's a super cool Library go
check it out but the main important
thing for the argument here is that it's
just a table I've like feature one
feature 2 uh all the way up until
feature 27 or 28 and these are all like
numeric features and then there's this
class that I'm trying to predict and
most of these are zeros there's a couple
of ones but I want to come up with some
sort of algorithm that can just tell me
hey was it fraud or
not and just to emphasize like you can
Group by the class and do a count and
you can verify that yeah this is like
imbalance that's definitely a part of
the issue
here but I still have no idea what's
happening in this data set it's just a
bunch of numbers so my first instinct
would be visualize this and
visualization is actually pretty darn
cool because um like an algorithm might
scale and a visualization might not but
a visualization can surprise you and an
algorithm typically
cannot but then the challenge is how on
Earth do I visualize like 28 uh features
that that feels kind of hard like
usually we like to see things in 2D but
in the like 80s and 90s a couple of
really cool techniques got developed um
to like do high dimensional
visualization is this thing called
parallel coordinates and we also have
browsers nowadays that are quick enough
to render them in semi-real time so
there's this really cool tool from um
Facebook made this actually that's
called high plot and and I'll take a
quick moment to explain what you're
actually looking at here but this is
what people like to call a parallel
coordinates chart um every one data
point in the data set is effectively a
line so uh this is like uh feature one
over here then we've got feature two and
the first line had a specific value uh
for like uh feature one and feature two
and because we've now got every column
uh vertically the line that goes through
everything is basically the one example
for my data set and this package is
pretty like neat you can like switch
these things around you can sort of move
them back and forth you can determine
the color right so I can say use this
column for coloring and then you know
this will update but what you can also
do is just use the uh class label to
define the
color and in this case like if it's blue
it's not fraud and if it's orange it is
fraud uh so like the orange you see that
there's a couple of like orange examples
that have a couple of values here that
do seem a bit distinctive from the blue
ones but that's exactly what we want if
you're building a classifier like okay U
maybe we don't need the algorithm so
what high plot what's kind of cool about
high plot as well is I can make these
selections so I could like say oh I want
to select a subset of data here and
maybe uh only want to select the rows
that overlap there so I'm able to sort
of play around with this a bit and if I
can deselect as
well but also means that if I just grab
a pen and paper and I just make this
selection here I can just not forget the
values that I've selected and when I
look at this this seems pretty orange so
okay let's just assume that everything
that falls into this region is just uh
fraud uh I can then tell this tool by
the way to just exclude these
rows and I can see there's actually
still a bit of orange left so I can
select
that um as I do this by the way notice
how most things are orange it's just
that there's a couple of blue lines here
those would be excellent candidates to
double check I think but okay let's
let's like another selection over here I
think with a double selection I can get
a more precise uh prediction or
something so okay I'll exclude those but
all right like there's still some orange
in here but just by using a
visualization technique I can just write
down the values that I used write a
little python function with an if El
statement if between these values fraud
if between these values fraud it's kind
of like a case when algorithm
and you know uh kind of where are my
slides oh hang
on open
recent there we
go so assume I did assume I do all that
uh and I write those values down and I
do a bit of a grid search
then I can actually write down the
values that I get so it turns out
they're actually not bad so if you want
to perform kind of okay on the credit
card data set and I'm being a bit
handwavy here because doing this manual
work with gr grit search is not the most
fair comparison but still roughly it
seems like I get like a 70% precision
and recall by using a visualization
technique which given the class
imbalance isn't bad but it gets even
better because what you can do is you
can go to the car blog which is a very
popular deep learning framework and they
have a tutorial on to use neural
networks for uh imbalanced
classification tasks where they use the
same data set and I really want to like
Caris is a really cool project and this
is an amazing blog the blog post is
there to like explain how to use Caris
it's not really meant to show the most
performant model but the tutorial ends
and it mentions the Precision recall
values and yeah I guess you could say
the recall is maybe a little bit better
but the F1 score and the Precision are
just way worse than the visualization
trick and I think that's kind of
interesting because people do read the
Caris blog as an authoritative Source
even though you know it's it really is a
great blog you can learn how to use
Caris you might not learn how to think
about models there but people will copy
it and even more interesting you should
probably not use Caris because you can
also use a random force and get an even
better score by the way that's also
something you can totally
do but now imagine that we just ask
ourselves the question like okay is the
random Forest a good idea here given the
stuff we've just seen in the
visualization
and if you think about it twice then
also the random Force might not be the
best choice and let me try to explain
that so before I showed you that you can
take a credit card data set you can
explore it you can build like a rule
based system based on the stuff that
you're learning so you can get inspired
by the visualization but you can
probably also come up with some of your
own rules but you can take a step back
not worry about the algorithm but you
can come up with a rule based
approach besides that you can have a
black box Caris random Forest what have
you with something that really tries to
like fit the data super well without
thinking about it what you can then do
is you can compare the two approaches
and see where the gaps in your knowledge
are if the rulebase system captures
something that a black box doesn't
why and if the rulebase system captures
something that the blackb doesn't again
you can ask why and actually learn
something this is human
learning but as you do this exercise
you're probably also going to just
recognize that you might be able to come
up with rules for for things that just
don't appear in the data but should be
checked as
well um if you're a 16-year-old and you
have a billion dollars on your bank
account I would check that even if
there's no example of that in my data
set beforehand like that is something
like a rule you can definitely add
yourself without doing anything with
data and then if you start thinking
about it some more you might also
realize something fundamental about this
problem and that's the issue with the
labels something we saw in a visual
like if the line was orange or if the
fraud label says it was definitely fraud
then that's actually pretty easy to
trust someone probably looked at that
probably a specialist some human and
yeah probably like the villain got
caught and is in prison now but like
it's very easy to trust that label it's
much harder to trust the label that says
not
fraud because how can I be sure it
wasn't fraud there's so many non-f fraud
cases I can't expect all the labelers
have seen all of those examples and that
is something that's like that thought is
a lot easier to get into your brain if
you don't follow the Black Box approach
blindly it's a lot easier to get this
idea or like this concern into your mind
if you try to take the breath first
approach as opposed to I will apply what
I've learned from the
book and I think this is again pretty
interesting I might argue that in this
case even if you would have gone with
the random Force as the best model which
is something the metric confirm it might
have distracted you from this very
important aspect of the
problem and in my experience people who
have been in fraud for like a year or
two they get this but people who just
start working in fraud tend to forget
this because they're not exposed to this
part of the problem sometimes because
they just overfit on the approach that
they're trying to
use and it's a really interesting
anecdote if we think about like
Reinventing Wheels related to the
transition from the bike to the left
uh to the bike on the right there's an
interesting Wikipedia page about this
actually it was pretty interesting
because there was a point in time where
people thought that this is the way you
should build
bikes and eventually people recognized
that that might be a much better idea
and the reason had nothing to do with
the wheel it had everything to do with
the pedal uh because this was super
unsafe to ride uh in order to ride that
thing you had to like hunch over and you
would be super high up from the ground
and once the wheel got momentum it would
like keep on spinning so if you hit
something you would like fly off head
first so people knew something had to be
changed and they had like a direction
where the thing had to go into and
eventually we got there but if you look
at the first designs that they made
transitioning from that bike to the one
that we eventually wanted to have you
can just see that they couldn't let the
idea of the big wheel
go right and it like they KN they had
they had a hint they knew it was super
unsafe but like it took them a couple of
years extra simply because this they
thought that this is how you build
bikes
with that in mind uh let's now talk
about word
embeddings um so I'm about to give like
the quickest introduction to what a word
embedding is like from a training
perspective I acknowledge that maybe not
everyone is sort of familiar with this
um so I'm going to be a little bit
handwavy for that if you want more
details come find me
after if you want to train like a
representation for a word a trick that
you might be able to apply is that you
say well maybe words that are close
together in a sentence are similar in
some way or
form um and you can argue things like
okay I can pet a dog I can pet a cat
Okay pet and dog is a similarity pet and
cat is a similarity uh maybe if we have
a representation for both words they
should be similar now how do you get
there lots of different ways but what
people typically like to do is like a
like a representation of a word like lot
an array with lots of zeros and the one
goes into a neural network and then we
try to predict the other words that
should be around there that's B I'm
really really skipping over lots of
details but it's like a way you could go
about that and if you have a neural
network you also have a hidden
representation and then if you then flip
the arrows around a bit after training
such a system you have a mapping from a
word to a vector and let's call that
word
embeddings lots of different ways you
could do this but let's for now assume
roughly this is the general
approach that means in practice that if
you have a sentence like have you seen
Star Wars Wars that you would have an
embedding for each
word right let called it word Tove but
for each word we've got this
vector and I think this example is
particularly interesting because if you
look at this example you can kind of see
that there's something wrong with
it because if I think what is similar to
Star right we have a representation for
have a representation for the word star
and the representation for the for the
word Wars but if I take the average of
those to word embeddings am I then close
to like Han Solo and Chewbacca and Darth
Vader maybe not I mean it's more likely
that if you have the word AB bedding for
star that that's maybe close to universe
and Wars maybe you're close to like
battle or something like that but the
whole concept of Star Wars is
like its own unique thing it's not you
cannot just merge two words and hope to
get the same meaning out ah but that's a
hint and we might be able to leverage
that if we think about tools that we
have available now which we didn't have
10 years ago um I work for a company
called explosion we have this tool
called Spacey and Spacey can provide you
relatively reliably um things like part
of speech so we can estimate whether or
not a word is a verb and we can estimate
where or not is a noun and to make
things even better we even have stuff
for grammatical
dependencies this is a statistical model
it's not necessarily perfect but if we
now rethink what we're doing
you can notice that we have like a
compound noun there and we also see that
there's this grammatical relationship
from the verb that goes
in and you can kind of Wonder Maybe on
top of that graph I can just come up
with some heuristics such as I say let's
chunk the nouns together and for all
intents and purposes pretend that that's
a single
token so instead of seeing star and Wars
as like two separate words if I apply
like some grammatical models and if I
can sort of figure out a heris to chunk
them
together maybe just maybe I can do
repeat the same word to ve thing but I
just changed the meaning of a token a
token isn't a single word anymore it's
much closer to something like a
phrase and if I think about stuff that
you typically want to detect like when
you're doing named entity recognition
you're typically interested in like noun
chunks not separate words you're
interested in finding a
concept but that means that maybe now
Star Wars as a noun like because we
again we still have the part of speech
stuff what happens if that's now a token
and that's pretty interesting because it
also means that duck as a noun might
also be a different token as duck as a
verb and I can have different word
embeddings for both and we might end up
with phrase embeddings this is a really
neat idea and again my employer has this
package called sense def ve that has
these embeddings it was trained on
Reddit and you can really rethink what
similarity means now because we're not
talking about words anymore we're
definitely closer to phrases and perhaps
even
Concepts still like the algorithm will
never be perfect but just think like a
demo of what you could do with this
right um You can go to the online demo
and you can type in kns of the Old
Republic which is a video game that I
used to play back when I was like 18 uh
it's a star wars-based video game like
it's super nerdy but if you then ask the
system like hey what are similar words
based on like the embedding of this
phrase now and we use something like
cosign similarity like what are the
other similar phrases then you get nice
of the Old Republic with capital letters
you get cotor which is like the online
abbreviation for the video
game we get abbreviations for free you
know that's actually like a huge problem
usually but those are in there we get
Jade Empire similar video games we get
the Jedi Knight series Mass Effect
different spellings for the cotour
abbreviation this is a really useful
embedding especially when you start
thinking about how you can use it so
let's say I'm interested in like finding
video games in text um I mean I can
start with something I like to call a
seed phrase where okay I'm interested in
finding video games like Knights of the
Old Republic um let's use it as a seed
let's get the embedding for
that then I have my unlabeled data with
lots of phrases and what I can then do
is just say well go over the phrases one
by one and just find me the ones that
are similar to the one that I start
with again cosine similarity is what I'm
using most similar to go first and then
me as a human I can just curate and look
at the most likely candidates first and
not have to go through entire data
set there's like a cool little human in
the loop and what's more maybe at some
point I've exhausted this seed phrase
but that's okay because I can reuse the
other entities for this
and I can actually look for Concepts in
my text and because this thing is
trained on Reddit you know uh we also
have slang and abbreviations so even if
you don't have perfect spelling we're I
mean not perfectly robust but there's
some robustness against
this and how on Earth would you have
gotten here if like your first notion of
oh I'm going to do entities is just
basic tokenization embedding feed
forwarding that to network and then
hoping that we get the right thing out
like the hard part is usually finding
the great labels so
maybe we got to focus on algorithms that
can help you with that and then once we
have good labels we can maybe do the
basic thing but this is again like one
of those ideas that feels hard to
grasp if you're so trained to think
about this problem in a certain
way and maybe we're distracted from
great ideas just because of the way that
we're used to thinking about it and that
got me wondering like what can I do to
ensure that I keep on getting great
ideas in front of me once in a while and
I'm partially doing this because Twitter
isn't what it used to
be um so let me explain my new hobby um
I really like to read archive
articles that introduce a new data
set and the reason is because they when
you introduce a new data set you
typically also have like a really weird
and novel task and I just get a lot of
inspiration from it and just to give an
example of Stu that I've seen there's
this data set that uh mentions a
comprehensive gold standard and
Benchmark for comic book text detection
and recognition so you know how comic
books have these speech bubbles turns
out that's a really interesting NLP and
OCR problem because they come in all
shapes and sizes especially when you get
to like comic books from the 50s which
is what they do and um not only did they
collect the data set they also like have
introduce a new model Etc but this is
great like I'm rethinking my Approach
here this is not not something I do
every day this is inspiring and you know
I have a tool for this now like uh
there's tons of people doing agriculture
photography now so if you want to have
Greenhouse tomato photos I mean there
are tons of public data sets about that
which is cool um I'm not into Dungeons
and Dragons but apparently there's this
professor that collected like uh role
playing game transcripts and they have
like a giant Corpus for like learning
character action interactions which is
something llm people like to do now um
but there's also other topics right like
data sets are super cool but there's
actually like some good psychological
research on how people like to code like
prog developer research stuff and like
is co-pilot good and can we measure that
uh I'm also really interested in data
sets that talk about um model eror like
label errors uh turns out that cyar 10
has duplicates um between its R and test
set with different
labels uh and like more and more people
are investigating these public data sets
for errors and that's also like a huge
favorite topic of mine I would love to
have a system that brings me stuff that
inspires me I would like to like
consider that the handson problem
nowadays again because Twitter is not
what it used to
be lucky for me archive is public the
giant uh like uh API for all these PDFs
is something that's publicly available
so I can scrape
that so that means I just need to build
a
classifier except this is actually one
of the more interesting classification
problems I've ever
seen let me explain that so you've
probably seen these pictures on the
internet where they do the embedding
thing and then they do the umap thing
and you get this pretty two-dimensional
uh visualization thing that gives you
the impression that there are all these
different
clusters you know uh what you kind of
hope for is that these clusters are kind
of well defined in hindsight so maybe
there's like a little economics cluster
there little NLP cluster here and like a
biology cluster there
and if you're doing like a text
classification that's exactly what you
want but are we really going to have a
separate cluster that only has data sets
or is a data set something that actually
appears in every cluster because you
have a data set in the field of biology
and you have a data set in the field of
physics and you have a data set in the
field of NLP and
everything this is kind of one of those
topics where the overlap of text is
actually super big and it's a pretty
tricky problem if you just think about
all the challenges the input for the
system is a pretty big abstract and
because it's big it has many
topics and I can definitely see how it
like just try to read this in a second
like it takes a while to read a whole
abstract and if it's hard for you to
annotate it's probably also hard for the
model to immediately figure out what to
do with it as
well so take a step back like can I
rethink this and very quickly I just
kind of noticed that that a lot of the
time not always I can also just read one
sentence from the abstract something
like additionally we introduced tomato
opedia a new large and challenging data
set of greenhouse tomatoes and then I
can just kind of go yeah that's enough
like if if a sentence like that appears
I don't have to read the rest of the
abstract basically I'm
done and you know sometimes there's two
sentences like that but maybe I
shouldn't think about this as like
standard text classification maybe I can
redefine the problem and just make it
simpler for myself and just worry about
sentences
instead all right how do you do that
well uh the luck is that this is archive
so it is pretty well spelled out like
there's no social media spelling or
anything so again I can reuse Spacey to
split this up into different sentences
and then for each sentence I can have a
classifier and then you know score comes
out if the score exceeds a certain
threshold algorithm can go found
one but the really cool thing about this
observation is that you shouldn't stop
thinking here because if you take a
moment you will also again remind
yourself
that just like it's hard to model an
abstract and just like how modeling a
sentence is relatively
easy if I have a sentence
model the same might hold for annotation
as well like I I don't have to rethink
just the model I can also rethink the
way that I get my training data because
I really am starting from
scratch so all right sentence model cool
idea I have this approach where I'm
collecting abstracts and I might
classify that
later but that means that now I can
start dreaming a little bit about how
I'm going to do these
annotations and that might lead to a
pretty fun demo
too so by the way um this is my front
page uh this is the way this is the
artifact that the system generates it is
an HTML file uh I can click uh the name
name of a data set the name of an
article and the system will tell me
which sentence is a sentence that made
it believe it was about a new data set
it gives me a little confidence score as
well there's a config file but okay I I
can click the link if I
want but let's let's open up another one
maybe this one is pretty
interesting oh hang on this one has the
sentence experiments show that our
method achieves state of-the-art cross
data set reconstruction on five zero
shot testing data
sets this is a wrong
classification and what I could do is I
could say well let's hope that Active
Learning will fix this but I can also
say well in my life system I see
something that my model does wrong so
what I really want to do now is find
examples like this and annotate those
first because this is a thing my model
does wrong right now I don't have to
worry about probability values just yet
I could just annotate
this so um what I also did is I kind of
made this really cute little interface
for myself so I can say front page oops
python DM front page
annotate and this is going to boot up a
bunch of custom stuff for me um I can
say I want to annotate a new label for a
new data set uh I want to annotate on a
sentence level I want to annotate using
an approximate nearest neighbor trick
and I want to find example similar to
this one data set this one
example you know takes a while to boot
up uh but eventually it does bur and
then I got a labeling interface where
you know I can kind of zoom in uh this
is again a sentence that not really
about a data set it's more about a
benchmark on a data set so this is
something I'm indeed interested in
labeling I can hit
no uh this also feels like it's about a
benchmark so again I can kind of hit no
and I do this for like 15 minutes I have
about you know 50 or so examples maybe
and I can
retrain and this is kind of nice because
I can liter steer my model into like
fixing the the bugs that I see it
do and what's actually kind of cool as
well like I have sentences right but I
also have
abstracts so I can leverage that and I
can do this trick that I like to call
second
opinion because if you have a model
that's actually kind of okay you can
also spin up an interface where it
actually just loads up the entire text
and it just tries to like hi
highlight the sentence that it believes
is the reason why this should be about a
new data set and you know I can have a
look at what it gets wrong I kind of say
well add this sentence you know can kind
of do thei
thing but if I now accept this entire
abstract my sentence model will get two
positive labels and about eight negative
labels and suddenly by annotating one
abstract I get about 10 examples to
train
on and that's actually kind of neat too
like if I spend more effort per example
my algorithm also gets more examples
from it and there's more than one way to
annotate this data set and the odds of
me getting surprised similar to the
visualization trick is pretty high
too and again the only way I you would
kind of get here is to sort of let go
the idea of how you should do Active
Learning you can kind of determine that
yourself and I I started like can I name
this like you normally if you read a
book like how do I annotate you kind of
read well you take your train model and
that model determines what to prioritize
but maybe this idea of act active
teaching is also just kind of cool where
the whole point is that I as the person
who understands the problem is in charge
of telling the algorithm what it should
learn and I can come up with all sorts
of cool tricks to help me find data sets
that are relevant like stuff that gets
wrong or just a couple of ristics that
make it likely for me to get examples
that I'm mostly interested in
and there's definitely more than one one
way to do this and I find it very
liberating to sort of rethink these
things simply because I'm afraid of
getting
stuck and looking at the time I I won't
go over all the details there's a bunch
of rethinking that you can also do when
training the system cuz um technically
what I'm doing here is like multi-label
classification but there's a couple of
missing values as well like if I'm
annotating for multiple labels uh it's
pretty likely I won't ever have a text
where I have a label for every example
so I cannot just pass it a matrix with
lots of nonv values Cy could learn isn't
really like that so for that there's
this other trick that I do um where
basically I train a system and I uh you
know do the for Loop train one label
first then the next one then the next
one um respect for time um but I think
it's fine to skip those details because
uh we're kind of getting to the point of
the talk I
guess
um hopefully I've been able to show you
some neat ideas and you might get
inspiration from this and you might
think oh I can reuse these ideas and you
should but it's not the point the point
isn't that from now on we should
recommend users to items all the time um
it's also not the point that you should
always get the inspiration for
visualization first and even though the
sentence model and all the active
teaching stuff I've just shown you I
think is really neat um these are just
examples the point of this talk is a
little bit more on what makes these
ideas possible in the first place or
rather what sort of things around us
might block these ideas from happening
is there anything that prevents us from
rethinking Wheels when we need to and
that brings me to a bit of a fear of
mine in this day and age because I think
that we might want to worry that the
current generation of data professionals
actually grows up thinking that we have
actually figured out how to think about
data problems
and the issue really isn't tools but
really the way that we think about them
because in real life you have a real
world problem that you translate to a
data
problem then you know you flow your
tensors you do your math stuff and maybe
you get a model that's in a better state
with a number this is data science right
um but it's not necessarily guaranteed
that the translation back to the real
world works like the algorithm might not
survive the impact with
reality and yet if I think about where
most creativity goes if I talk to data
people they tend to love to talk about
the left side of this diagram there's
not too many conversations about like
hey are we solving the right problem are
we thinking about this the right way and
if I have to take a step
back I think the issue is that we might
be used to a certain way of thinking and
that there might be this little
monoculture around that and I like to
call this the optimality Trap because it
can be so tempting to chase a single
number and like completely drive into
that rabbit
hole especially if you surround yourself
with peers who have the same
training
and I don't know like maybe you forget
what it can be like to have new ideas
and that's scary to me and it's not just
in models that you have this I think the
whole mlops thing also suffers from this
a little
bit if you're knee deep in a specific
like stack and all the tools that belong
that to that stack convince you that
this is the way you should do machine
learning how on Earth will you ever
consider an
alternative or maybe even worse maybe
you're so invested in your way of
thinking that you actually believe
you're optimal while being completely
blind to the gorilla in your data set
you'll have the most say they are tools
and totally miss out on the problem part
that matters
most so the most interesting thought
then is maybe how can we actually find
this gorilla
metaphorically so I do think in general
tools and knowledge are good things um
if for example you didn't have the skill
set of a programming language to make
this chart in the first place um it
would not have worked like you do need
tools and techniques at your disposal
and also we've got like Decades of
computer science that we can go ahead
and reuse we can apply first principles
so it's in my mind it's probably not the
tools that are the
issue maybe the way we think about our
tools is the issue and that kind of
brings me to that article in the
beginning like if a hypothesis can be a
liability in statistics then in our
field maybe familiarity is also a
liability if you're really training to
think in a certain way um about you know
your problems by being familiar you
might trigger this oh I know how to do
this reaction without even thinking
about it and that's not always a bad
thing but it can be a liability and
sometimes it also can be a
tragedy and that's mainly if you're
eager to be seen as an expert and I feel
I should mention mention this both as a
recovering consultant but also in this
era of data
influencers expertise can also be a
liability if you think about it and and
here's what I mean by that like if you
want to be seen as an
authority you really have to convince
yourself that you know what you're doing
like you have to double down on it and
that promotes tunnel
vision and if you convince yourself that
you figured it out it becomes a lot
harder to recognize that you might need
a new idea
it's a lot harder to be creative and you
might get stuck repeating the same
trick and if this is the reason that
we're missing the
gorilla that will be an honest
tragedy but there is a bit of Hope if we
think back about this
again so in this case that feeling of
this is how you design bikes is
precisely the thing that made it harder
to design a better one but we did get
there and the reason was we had a really
good reason to
doubt we knew that something was wrong
with that pedal we knew it was unsafe
and that at some point people just
caught attention of it they were
doubting the original design and because
they had a good reason to doubt it they
were able to take a step back and during
this talk I've given a few examples
where an improvement was made and if you
pay attention you may notice that each
of them was kind of sparked by doubt
doubt can be an escape hatch
there was a a notion that the original
plan had flaws and because we were able
to pay attention to it we were able to
sort of
escape and it might be a generational
thing like when I started ml there were
just not enough tools for everything so
we just knew that we didn't know
everything so we just tried a whole
bunch of stuff and I'm a little bit
worried that this generation is
forgetting to do that so just some
advice like Grant yourself a blank
canvas once in a while like really give
yourself the space to think less about
tools and honestly think more about
ideas like make time to reflect try to
understand the reason of Doubt as much
as you can and also like Grant yourself
some time to play because you can be a
serious person without taking yourself
serious because if you do that you'll be
much more receptive to great ideas that
will genuinely get you
unstuck and I also have some good news
cuz if you want to do these
things natural intelligence is is all
you need cuz I don't think we'll get
artificial doubt anytime soon and the
main point is that art natural
intelligence is something that we all
need I would really prefer a future
where you're always able to think for
yourself and to come up with your own
Solutions instead of being limited to
the tools that some vendor gives you and
there's more way more than one way to
think about a problem and it' really be
a shame if we ever forgot that and got
stuck
so please Grant yourself creative
freedom because otherwise you just risk
on losing some great
ideas one more
thing that archive front page thing I
made um you can Fork that like that's on
GitHub and I would love it if people
sort of take inspiration from this and
start doing this too but for topics that
you are interested in and what I would
leave love even more is that if you find
really cool articles that you just start
a little blog with a today I learn
section which is what I do
where I have blog posts with like maybe
one or two sentences basically
describing the cool idea in the article
just to make sure that that idea is
archived and doesn't get forgotten
because again ideas are
fragile I didn't have enough time to
talk about everything I wanted to but if
you're interested in this data set and
how we model this uh I am giving the
workshop on labeling later today so you
can actually play around these labels um
so if you're interested in that do come
by I'm also at the explosion Booth uh
and I guess the main thing I want to say
is like thanks for listening and uh